If you remember the
apprentices do you have
a few one black i know in areas. He lives
in maria and the room or rather you know
like named kennedy. Do you remember. Any
anything amusing that used to go on
around there. Not really i don't think
i don't think i did because i kept the
mostly to me suffer my girlfriend. We never
talked about much yet together we use our
dances every friday night and all of the
time you know really good night because i
don't even that nineteen of the twenty
you know and. The scotts a great one
for the thing and the answer is
a play for girls occasions and we get the
name of the other things they support on
the you know better. Ball or whatever
the ball over time that night on
a friday night everybody. Know it and
they get on the grog just like there's
a back home brew y bit but it was wine or
whiskey or something like that would be
ok but you know he was going all right.
Really good night. So they raised him and
that settled everything up. They
cut it all out then you know he's
a bloody classic that night
. You know then at the turn itself the
dancers used to play the fiddle. Yeah yeah
yeah. And where do you find the rest of the
band where no fiddle player there where
the piano. There they come
from there and they had
a drum of their i don't know with anyone
else what else they had because i can't
think back that far. I know that
it's about the fiddle and there's
a play but i think you know but by jeez
i tell you what we're some nights. Good
nights. Do you remember the the crushing
of the aggregate. How was that done.
What's that. Well you know the stone
waste was crushed for for metal for the
concrete and that while i don't i don't
think that done that down there. I don't
remember that back in the crushing public
trashing plant there could have been one
that used to take it. I think they brought
out the breakwater maria breakwater out
of the way stuff that came from
there. There must have been
a crushing machine because it used to go
in the bottom these to put it all the all
the aggregate in the bottom of the of the
ships. Yeah i don't remember that that
part of it because i didn't take much
notice of that one interesting part of it
that could be done at the back.
But i never remember of it. Of
a crashing plane could have been on there
and when you finished or how did you
finish up there. Well i got
hurt on the foot there i went i
got right i just left and
come back to sydney against
a worldly it was the end of the job and he
was nearly cut people out and would have
been there much many more months because
that was the last of it all the other part
of you done. Did you get a job again
in sydney i came to sydney. Did i get
a job in sydney now thirty one. Well i
can't. When now i think
things was a bit bad that was
a depression and i see you to get
little jobs in my get a week
a year around i pretended i gained on
doing freestone something like that until
things got a bit better later
on then i buy them if i get
a couple of years you've got lucky to get
it. You've got to get it you can get dull
if they get today. You
couldn't get. For nine and
a week. You've got if you didn't live at
home. Well my mother. I stopped at home
and i didn't five years i never
worked for five years. I got my i got
a job then cause. I went right
on into my lap to try and
realize you were on the dole yourself. No
i couldn't get it because ultimately home
. I just got a week's
work out your parent had
a keeper couldn't get the phone not want
a week. Even if i left. Um i could have
got it but i'm living at home now to keep
me your father working there.
What was he working as
a dairy farmers isn't tied to the horses
the dairy farms. Was it round here round
a basket. Down there and i could if i got
a job later on i got plenty of work
after worked on the i got onto the to
a place called this down yard over here.
I used to go over there and work at
different times when you want to me like i
might i might not get no pay it when you
sold us. We sold a stone or sold some
stuff i'd get a pay out of it then my get
a dollar to dollar something like
that and then it. We got got
a job it can be around the i think
it was the lot. The. And that was
a war museum all the
flagging for it. I think was
a museum in nineteen that come
later or nineteen coming to 1940.
Was forty. Cause i was married
and then i started then because
after that graving dock came on the garden
island driving dock and of course we
were i was in the army for about two weeks
taken out to go into the dock because
that was more important. I reckon
and that was of was with with
a broomstick or actually or something to
remember who was in charge of the grabbing
the. No there are four firms out it
seems but i was told that james muir who
was in charge of the sydney harbour bridge
that was on it. I had
a name familiar. You could have been but
i i didn't i was in the yard see and act
and in i was in we were i would act and
they are here. Estonia used to be here.
That was when it works. There was they be
acton's in alexandria. There were so and
does that. Pain to know
and love and hutchins up lewisham they were
forum at that set up between them. Well
after all the stones that were similar to
the similar work to the to the to the to
the parlance. But there wasn't much rough
inner. Rough work but all faced when done
by sorting it then it will be will
be about to get a stone about
a ton you cut in about four and
a half time of the time to be cut down
and checked out and finished for the one
that was all i'm going to work with bevels
there and gauges and strategies. That'll
be perfect watertight gateways not the
keeping on the top as well. Right. After
that was all finished they were checked
by inspectors every week your tools are
used straight edges and squares were all
checked every week and when it was all
completed they spat all fit perfect. And
when i went down to the when it and i said
it all up on the dock. They took a check
a sight of my again or some might
have been an eighth of an inch
a quarter inch out and weary face all
those down on the job in the dock itself
that's where the gates go along and
they float and i come down out of
a perfect. No water have
a face on there and what are going
to be no good because the right dog
a flood. So that'll be a strategy put
a strategy all along and you
look right down or you put
a cigarette paper down between the back.
Well that's out perfect it had to be. And
we were then if about nine months on those
that been set in already before it was
used and that's like that big gates along
flood i mean they bring them all and i
find they've got champers
on their they go like
a bull no no. Top you know come along and
champion and coming straight down to join
me to get
a nice reverse side and then they fit it
drops the gate. Comes along when the water
is there and they flood that down minutes
when that thing is set down they pump the
water out and it's the dry dock that's out
has to be perfect it was that was the
work more exacting or just about the same
as how it was it was more exacting but
the bridge was near it was it was pretty
purp because you had all these bubbles to
go boy to go by all these people's and
that the different size fourteen foot as i
said before forty one fall into fourteen
trees and that's all you've ever goes up
so you get different stones different you
know to get them so they come in. I don't
see that any trouble in there when they
set them. Well it was only to masons the
side two two on the north pole and two
in the south. I don't know them well
i've got their names and there's none of
them alive and well i think there's one of
them alive. If i knew their names i might
have known them but i wouldn't have known
in those articles as i say i just come
out of my time and they'd be probably
a lot of our base i mean they'd be some
you never see that right around one time.
Tell me when you in your time. How long
was your apprenticeship five years. And
during the procedure. During the apprenticeship
how did you start. I started by and
abilities first and us then after
about running around i give you
a bit of stone to make around
with a hammer a punch around not
a bit often you do something else and after
about twelve states that you know then
and then they give you. We don't. The first
job that i worked on in the stone game
was the other government in the bank as
i told you before all that it'll called
around the top water in the top but other
than you. I mean there must be two or
three hundred guys right around the top
and we that was our i got fighters i mean
the you'd like to see them signing when
you're ready and then we started off then
you get on to other work then
as you progress and seen a job
a job you made them but you've got better
and better and better and that's how you
you move on. Do you end up cutting large
blocks to you on the graving dock
and but on these other the
other job down here the the
way i caught the tech station department
oppose what they call that place now that
was all done by swords and
a lot that were done by machinery but some
some stones they were never worked on in
the six weeks to make it six weeks to polish
some of those ones to get over the top
those grow and weeks go and. There anything
you. Else that you comes to mind about
the career maria on the harbor
bridge work. I know i'd only
put
a car over there. I can't take this girl
to batemans bay one day and one of these
pac ads i think was
a packard. Or one between those days to be
you know again and not down the road to
well until you put up with
a ben record that would have been not
talked about for up and then come back
they're going to make million from batemans
bay tomorrow it will make. Even i don't
know about ninety you know i do any experience
in country roads and down the quarry
a few times or sloppy and you get that mad
and you know you've got to get out of it
and i say turn the car and then the
other part you play of as i did use
a plaintiff in the football team
then oh yeah but they called
a scratch game went on
a soccer. I would know soccer from rugby.
If i played it but we had to go get our
long tree and the quarry and it versus the
stonemasons everything was in boots and
all in the long. That's an hour race course.
Where was the race course still down
south in the morale of the town. So we're
used to play soccer there. Now that's
where we used to go. Not all the time
a few to and we tried you know
when they when they declared us on
a weekly they won boots on
or in any cricket match.
What
a good enough for them. It sounds of the
scots or in charge their socks. I were in
charge of everything they were
a great team of people great what was soccer
in the dancing really good really good
. Remember anything else as well.
We should. Know i mean right
used to buy turkeys down there for four
dollar repair and sent up to sydney to my
mother every week for two bob transport.
To do today will. Where did you get
the turkey's back you come from
a place where alone. I had a real
sort of relation to my my i had
a relation to relations up over that
area. In fact from there i did he did
he don't equate the site in the early age
by canberra name herbert. Well known in
that area. Another i went out went out to
one of these like say that type macquarie
. And he started a gold crash in plant. I
got out there one day to have a look at
a higher car service down there to feel
about that other band different time
when i went down there with me to see this
plant there was sticky beaten around me
translate got caught up in
a shaft and i'm singing out like hell and
they wouldn't listen to me and i mean for
me to address right off one like the pin
on the end of the shaft got caught in the
bottom academy tried a
brand new suit to try to
a threat right out of it. Mr key on the
end of the on the end of the shaft the
little bolt on the unit out of the the
neck of the bloody the key in there
was
a near miss fully what i would that they
couldn't hear the noise it made they make
the dollies are going up and down you
know and now they just have to say oh my
trousers went out i still went under.
That's under to win. Because of
a button to look.